alors c'était une télévision locale
bon parce que la scène tels viols au
calme le doute est un soldat est
toujours dit qu'il était installée la
copc le conscientiser commune j'en ai
souvent les rois venaient tous les jours
passent tous les jours et souvent aussi
évoqué
je te permet d'aller voir ailleurs
[Musique]
télé soja est donc née en 1978 en
franche comté dans le haut doubs
parallèlement à la création d'un cinéma
itinérant un magazine d'actualités
locales de 20 minutes environ et est
diffusé en avant-première des séances de
ciné club en 1982 télé sauget prend son
autonomie et devient une vraie
télévision par câble longueur du câble
deux mètres cinquante qui diffuse un
magazine d'actualités mensuel d'une
heure environ dans les seize villages du
canton de montbenoît on l'appelle alors
la télé brouette une bonne vingtaine de
bénévoles et trois permanents se
partagent les activités de production et
de diffusion
tous participent à la création d'une
société pour obtenir l'autorisation
d'émettre sur le réseau et retient donc
au début de l'été 1988 télé sauget des
ménages direction l'habillement deux
mois pour dijoux d'une intense
programmation avec le tracteur de juger
qui avaient fait le voyage exprès pour
nous
[Applaudissements]
d'ici sa demande d'avoir un dossier bien
construit bien pensée ou se fait un peu
par par relation dit non non non pas du
terme d'un an
je ne connaissais personne à la cmcm je
ne connaissais pas dan politique qui
pouvait intervenir
on a fait vraiment ça tout seul sans
aucune intervention de qui que ce soit
j'ai simplement envoyé un dossier g
après communiquer avec la personne qui
s'occupait de ce dossier pour aménager
certaines choses certaines certains
points de programme le temps de
publicité etc
c'est dire que il ya un règlement qui
salua petit cahier des charges bien
accueillis des charges pour ce les
télévisions temporaire et on va on
essaye simplement de respecter ce cahier
des charges mais vous avez eu l'argent
pour on a fait des dossiers de demande
de subvention a traditionnellement à nos
partenaires et une part du financement
non négligeable et le bénévolat l'abbaye
de montbenoît s'est transformée d'un
coup en ruche bourdonnante de gens d'ici
et d'ailleurs
une fourmilière de bénévoles de béotiens
de militantes professionnels on avait
tous l'impression de participer à une
révolution minuscule mais pas si
d'ancienneté
[Musique]
bonjour voilà la suite la voilà je ne
sais pas j'ai bien du mal à savoir
combien vous le regardez en ce moment et
pour vous expliquer de tout ce qui va se
passer pendant cette semaine comme je ne
suis pas un orateur un animateur hors
cadre j'en ai deux là qui sont tout à
fait cadres et je m'excuse donc à 18
heures couleurs locales
info du crdp ensuite 18h10 salue les
mômes sais pas si vous aimez moi j'adore
c'est les petits poucets un des paris de
cette expérience était de s'adresser à
tous les publics est d'exposer une
production alternative de courts
métrages est de films d'animation les
grandes heures de télé c'est aux ges
c'est aussi les débats en direct avec
des sujets comme les travailleurs
frontaliers la chasse et la pêche
les grandes surfaces et les petits
commerces l'environnement et les plus
acides
le soja mythe ou réalité les quotas
laitiers le tourisme les télévisions
locales au port ne touchez pas au poste
nous sommes bien sûr télécharger ce soir
teyssot-gay pourparlers sur ce plateau à
plateau des pommes vous avez pu le voir
deux passions la chasse et la pêche les
débats du soir un peu plus de tenue
car on avait choisi qui doit animer et
par des journalistes professionnels et
certains étaient même venus avec plaisir
de france 3 pour participer à cette
aventure jaribu je promène mon fusil
et quand on dit que les chasseurs sont
des viandes or qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ce niveau pourquoi parce que
les chasseurs acharné des pales
viandards c'est le meilleur protecteur
de la nature
combien d'années je pense que je ne fais
pas quarantaine d'années c'est vrai
qu'on est berckois aouij est arrivé à
tous chasseurs de pêcheurs de braconner
ouais pas d'accord ça commence à
s'animer un petit peu je crois que ça se
déchaîne
[Musique]
vous avez vous déposé permis de
construire tout aliment des
autorisations pour faire ce bâtiment oui
on nous l'a permis alors je vous pas la
maison pourquoi alors justement le
problème enfin disons le problème il
existe par le fait qu'il ya des gens qui
se plaignent ils disent bon côté c'est
pas incroyable ce site là c'était
vraiment jolie c'était très typique
l'est de la région
et puis maintenant on se retrouve avec
un hangar métallique nous ça nous plaît
pas du tout voilà la réaction des gens
du coin de l'environnement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous et nous ça nous a
permis de le faire trouver les caisses
que les journalistes n'étaient pas
agressifs et les thèmes des débats
passer forcément par des exemples très
locaux je vais peut-être vous présenter
maintenant nous invité ce soir qu'ils
sont tous autour de la table pour pas
les invités avaient tout le loisir
d'exprimer leur passion
c'était ça tout l'intérêt hubert vieille
va animer ce débat vers dont je crois
que la première question qui se pose aux
valeurs de ces images question du rhin à
ivo du quidam que je suis fatalité ou
nécessité père je suis là faire depuis
le début
d'autant plus qu'à des endroits qui me
donnait plus cher gelé souvent pas j'en
ai fait des beats graphie chapelle sa
maison des fours cattier c'est un des
petits hameaux j'ai débuté que j'appelle
le amont parce que c'est ce petit hameau
la gelée vue il a détruit le site est
détruit c'est à dire qu'il est à mes
yeux inutilisable on peut pas dire
j'emmenais mes amis quand je vais la
montrer à mon tipi du haut doubs
conserver prise après c'était celui-là
ce paysage et à moi comme il est à toi
comme il est aux autres il a tout le
monde mais il n'était pas inscrit dans
la loi
ça fait partie d'une espèce de tradition
communes à l'humanité et jadis il
fallait tellement de temps pour
transformer un paysage sam était
tellement d'années pour pour construire
une maison jose s'arranger un peu
d'elle-même elle
les gens étaient raisonnables maintenant
avec les moyens x 1000 qu'on a de
construire on peut en prendre les jours
complètement bouleversé un paysage et
détruire l'âme d'un village l'âme du
village de maisons neuves n'existe plus
dit jean gars qui vient se coller face à
la façade principale qui bouchent la vue
du mont d'or qui est le paysage
privilégiée de ces gens à quelque chose
d'incongru de de criminellement d'accord
on peut être que d'accord avec ce soir
là un individu avait été mise en cause
dans un débat demande un droit de
réponse
comme il n'habite pas loin il arrive
dans les dix minutes et le débat on
recommence je vais essayer de résumer ce
qu'a dit jean bataille et son sens
d'efforts mais parce que je ne veux pas
qu'on me relevant d'un droit de réponse
jean bataille a dit d'une certaine façon
que les prix coup faisiez de vos
produits dont l'invité était en fait été
possible parce que quand vous vous tirez
sur les salaires quoi j'ai résumé donc
de ces de ce fait je veux pas aller plus
loin on dira mu monsieur bataille a été
très impoli très malhonnête vis à vis de
moi parce que je pense que j'ai assez
souffert pour créer mon entreprise
étrangère sont insultés par des gens qui
m'ont j'ai vu travailler pas encore en
15 ans avec moi qui ne foutent rien de
la journée pour reprendre les mots comme
ils sont donc je suis venu pour défendre
mon cas à cause de ceci sert à bien
gérer
alors merci daniel girardin quand vous
avez pu montrer soir qu'une télévision
de type telesso jaquette sporadiques et
épisodique eux peut aussi être facilité
je dirais la démocratie locale et
l'expression de j'avais pas et j'allais
dire les lobbys maintenant
entre courses et des jours de délai nous
avions produit nous mêmes les trois
quarts des programmes documentaires
magazines archives et sur le plateau de
l'abbaye un plateau du 12e siècle dans
l'émission couleurs locales
les habitants du haut doubs étaient
accueillis chaleureusement
il mesure combien de circonférence de
biens mètres de diamètre nous m'avez dit
que vous l'avez cueilli hier sa wii
c'est chopin ce qui va pousser d'une il
a poussé du nul
on peut vous demander où ça pousse au
four au four et nous faut sur quelle
tâche
ah ça vous le dites pas parce que vous
êtes un fan champignonneurs neuf ans
d'accord comme pour savoir quand il faut
les cueillir
qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien on regarde
la météo et puis demain il va faire quel
temps mais moi je crois que tant leur
maître wade en 1h fait je n'ai en
nouvelle lune maintenant l'épreuve après
son premier quartier mais je crois que
ça peut repartir au mot maintenant très
souvent quand on a dû - être comme ça
des fois que ces saumons de charme et de
temps oui on change de lune ne peut pas
savoir le reste j'en vis à côté d'une
amélioration pas su dire ça la neige le
temps des gens les hirondelles qui sont
partis ou peugeot se battraient jours
les hirondelles sont partis ce parti va
dire puisque le faire c'est une bonne
joly s'est tenue à tabasser de crécy et
puis les quatre soleils dumas ouais les
quatre soleils
ouais c'était très beau temps ah bon
gilles tu serais plus on en effet après
et maintenant qu'est ce qu'on va faire
alors comment alors je repose la
question et maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
va faire
ça y est ça marche ça marche ça tourne
rond gilles ça tourne ça comment après
c'est cette expérience très réussie de
télévision temporaires tels et sauget
vous n'avez pas autant dormir sur vos
deux oreilles
vous avez déjà travaillé pendant 10 ans
pour multiplier les contacts dans la
formule que vous appelez les brouettes
vous terminez un feu d'artifice qui est
très réussi et maintenant il faut que
vous continuiez de façon à un chemin
faisant et en continuant votre brouette
cadres et une perspective qui lie à mon
avis toi tu être la faute
difficile compliquée qui est celle d'une
télévision permanente à mes yeux la
télévision ce n'est pas forcément et
systématiquement un moyen d'exotisme
soit dans la réalité il soit par la
fiction policière ou n'importe quoi il
ya également un besoin pressant de
l'homme de se retrouver lui-même dans
son petit et trois petits milieux et à
mon avis c'est très important quand ça
réussit comme ça mais là je suis un peu
étonné même créé réussissent de spectra
et donc ça amène les gens forcément à
réagir mais je vous ai terminé avec les
fusions j'ai l'impression ça me donne
l'impression d'un d'un prestidigitateur
qui réussit un coup formidable et alors
il est temps que tout le monde mais on
se dit il nous dit brusquement et ex
abrite peut il nous dire ah bah le vous
pouvez pas nous la refaire le coup je ne
sais pas si je pourrai alors pour moi
c'est un peu tragique s'est terminé de
façon tragique
est ce que c'est un coup d'essai ou si
c'est le début de quelque chose
et voilà et voilà cette expérience de
télévision temporaire nous a permis de
savoir si faire de la télé locale
hertzienne en milieu rural en moyenne
montagne était possible tester les
programmes passent à mettre en place une
diffusion hertzienne encore plus
difficile quant à trouver du financement
c'était quasiment impossible d'année
prochaine cseries ans dans dix ans etc
j'espère bien qu'on refera quelque chose
parce que je me rappelle ça a été
quelque chose de passionnant parce qu'il
y avait eu une belle effervescence un
vrai plaisir à travailler ensemble tous
les gens qui étaient réunis une équipe
en sorte éphémère qui venaient de divers
horizons mais tous toqués de télé et ce
qui m'avait marqué moi c'était à la
fosse ce plaisir collectif à travailler
ensemble dans quelque chose de festif de
libre de joyeux mais quand même de
rigoureux et de créatifs et puis à la
fois ce lien qui était réel avec les
habitants puisque je pense que telle et
sauget en tout cas l'expérience télé
soyez chez vous a montré que va faire de
la télévision locale s'était aussi être
dans un rapport social avec ses voisins
avec avec ceux et celles qui sont filmés
et c'était moi ce qui m'avait marqué moi
qui suis né devant un post à lui mais
c'était je découvrais en fait ce lien
avec l'autre qui est son projet son
voisin est configuré au quotidien et
enfin on a l'impression en vous écoutant
en revisitant cette période que c'est
une décade de direct où il ya eu un
véritable bonheur de faire ensemble et
c'était pas si courant à cette époque et
quelques expériences comme ça en france
dont celle là qui est marquante je crois
nous balance king a surtout marqué et
nous c'est les les problèmes en avant l'
on les a su bien après quoi de réception
des téléspectateurs potentiels
et ça ça c'est un regret quoi
si son histoire l'eau fait en 88 oui
c'était bien me donner la taper la balle
mais on a vu arriver mais ça c'est pas
de notre faute on comprend pas ce que le
réseau le réseau tdf a le réseau les
émetteurs là qui sont parfaits pour
câbler tout le monde ou pas ils sont pas
faits pour faire du local ils sont faits
pour faire du régional donc faire une
télévision on peut pas faire une
télévision
le piper locale mais pour les petits
villages uniquement avec les avec les
émetteurs
c'est très difficile de faire d'eux les
retient que là on s'est aperçu avec les
retiens qu'on pouvait pas ça marchait
pas à quoi un qu'on pouvait pas le faire
à ce moment-là on a rencontré fr3 on a
dit voilà on fait des émissions mais on
a pas moyen d m c'est à dire que au lieu
de payer une somme faramineuse de
factures tdf ou ou même des lois des
émetteurs voilà on utilise fr3
uniquement pour un émetteur et en plus
ça coûte moins cher toi tu le reçoit je
sais que tu reçoives et on peut toucher
plus de monde on touche aussi bien les
gens de ces mots belliard de dijon
d'auxonne
alors certains parmi les responsables de
ces télévisions est espéré un moment que
la troisième chaîne du service public
les accueillerait l'intérieur de
reprogrammation ça s'est fait avec la
télé gazette les alpes du sud télé
millevaches a tenté d'être téléchargées
à distance par le réseau de france 3 ça
va pas marcher n'ont pas accepté donc
l'alliance avec le service public ne
s'est pas fait
effectivement cette alliance n'a pas
réussi de façon permanente
toutefois françois beaucoup de franche
comté a permis d'accueillir télé sauget
avec son magazine la vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour aujourd'hui nous avons un
reportage sur les fêtes de village et un
portrait de ricoh de l'assaut
aujourd'hui la vidéo est sans frontières
puisqu'elle nous propose un reportage
sur les alpages propre suisse ainsi que
le portrait de piles ou l'accordéoniste
frontaliers aujourd'hui nous allons
faire le point sur le corégone élever la
voix
c'est comme ça qu'on a passé un quart
d'heure par mois à france 3 donc tous
les mois pendant cinq ans la télé brouet
toujours aussi pop art et par la poste à
la régie finale de france 3 ainsi tous
les spectateurs de bourgogne de
franche-comté profiter du bon air du
saugeais le vrai action peut pas l'envié
c'est si on l'est à certains mots comme
on les plonge comme on est à pékin sa
vie beytout gauche une fille belle
occase et d'adré avez vous chopez non
bon quand vous n'aurez pas changé depuis
tout gosse
vous ne pouvez pas changer comme il faut
après vous escamoter le nom des gens
qu'on secure qui nous valut autrement
oui mais non pas l'accent de soja comme
moi c'est pas pour me vanter bien loin
de là mais depuis le berceau concours au
japon l'a beaucoup maintenu en famille
le matin une solide vous preniez le café
la môme avait d'être président est le
café on passe à l'écurie
il fallait bayer voce louvain de la
grunge
on va traire et patronales des pays plus
abreuver les voce après on a fini au
turbin diplômes à des durées à mon sac
j'ai à mon ballon to joy temps murray
yam romy mairie pour du tout beau plutôt
que de ta bande
une des rares l'exigence de notre
hébergeur diffuseur émetteurs france 3
de notre petite niche mensuelle d'un
quart d'heure c'était de faire deux
sujets c'est ainsi que nous avons créé à
la fin de saison
la gentiane passer de l'un à l'autre
bonjour aujourd'hui outré mission si
vous l'acceptez consiste à casser du
sucre sur le dos
[Musique]
il me semble que ce qui nous motivait
c'était de nous dire qu'on faisait une
émission une vraie mission de service
public c'est à dire que se confirme elle
a par le petit bout de notre lorgnette
ça pouvait intéresser bien d'autres gens
en dehors de ce micro territoire quoi et
qui avait une vraie volonté de donner la
parole aux habitants mais d'y mettre
aussi du sens et de porter un regard en
tout cas différent de celui que porte
habituellement les journalistes roi
cette liberté située ça ne coûtait quand
même ça nous coûtait parce qu'on n'avait
pas beaucoup de financements tous les
ans de la pêche aux subventions et au
bout de cinq ans du même dossier
les finances se sont épuisés et nous
changer parce que ce qu'on avait envie
c'était quand même d'accéder aux tuyaux
et d'une manière plus pérenne plus
fréquentes même si on n'avait pas envie
de contribuer au bien exerça on a
développé plein de projets grands le
grand canal télé jura la maison de la
communication
télévisa qui aussi a de même le temps
sur le câble en même temps tu es parti
sur mulhouse au site a animé une
télévision locale éphémère il y avait
été les hôtes foire en face à fourmiller
de projets sur lesquels à chaque fois on
s'accrochait en se disant c'est
peut-être le bon tient peut-être que par
ce petit bout là le réseau câblé de mort
tous de besançon il y avait comme ça des
opportunités à chaque fois il me
semblait qu'on se disait on va y arriver
quoi cet avis on n'est pas arrivé parce
qu'il y avait aussi tout un contexte
politique économique qui fait que c'est
toujours l'histoire elle se continue en
fait puisque les débats ils sont
toujours là d'une autre manière pour
qu'il puisse y avoir
l'émergence on va dire
complémentairement grande grands médias
ou à côté d'eux d'une autre parole enfin
et d'une autre manière de faire la
télévision surtout considère pas quelque
chose qui descendent sans arrêt vers les
gens mais où ils puissent s'impliquer
quoi il s'était quand même ça qu'on
revendique et disons que ça n'a pas
abouti sous cette forme là mais voilà
une aventure continue
[Musique]
de l'autre est-ce que vous pensez que ce
serait possible de faire ça maintenant
il a existé avec le public et je
comprends pas que je dise ça surprend
plus personne de soirée télé monde a
énormément changé
ça vous appelle ça peut tuer tout aussi
fait leur âge
voilà ce que tu construis rénale shu et
sociales jésus parce que eux ils ont
l'offre khamis copie l'on peut faire de
plus en plus proposer un truc comme ça
il faut quelque chose de bêtes de lui a
dit oui beaucoup de confiance
alors pourquoi ça s'est pas développé je
pense qu'il ya moi je dirais pas ça
s'est pas développée c'est à dire que
les l'été les brouettes les vidéos de
pays elles sont peut-être pas développé
peut-être même que ça s'est arrêté la
plupart sont arrêtés mais je pense que
ça a été le ferment de de télévision
qu'on voit maintenant ici dans les
halles qu'on a tv8 mont blanc sacré été
créés en 89 donc il ya quand même très
longtemps elle a déposé ville en deux
fois elle a été relancée par une
association c'est l'association jean-luc
est l'actionnaire majoritaire
tv8montblanc et elle fait exactement de
la même façon elle essaie d'aller le
plus près dans tous les villages
elle essaie d'aller au fin fond des ddd
vallée de maurienne et c'est exact c'est
à mon avis la problématique est très
très proche on a envahi par les grands
couples services marchands intéresse que
les télévisions locales associatives ou
encore leur place oui elles ont encore
plus leur place justement parce que il y
à ces groupes et qu'il doit y avoir un
équilibre avec un secteur non marchand
associatif et ses porteurs de projets de
toute cette télévision
elle continue il continua à se battre
pour que des conditions économiques
soient réunies pour faire vivre ces
télévisions d'une façon pérenne parce
que ces projets sont des projets
socioculturels qui ne sont pas des
projets d'entreprises qui ne sont pas
des projets qui serait soutenu par un
business plan comme il faut le faire et
le présenter au csa lorsqu'on répond un
appel un appel d'offres pour une
fréquence qui s'ouvre donc il faut
qu'ils aient un fonds de soutien
à l'instar du système qui existe pour
les radios les radios libres
les radios associatives et il faut
également qu'il y ait des possibilités
pour l'avenir sur la télévision
numérique terrestre
réserver des fréquences aux télévisions
associatives et puis sur le haut débit
l'adsl c'est utopique
mais l'histoire de télé sauget n'est pas
tout à fait terminé toute l'équipe s'est
mobilisée une dernière fois autour d'une
superproduction autant de la fée verte
et s'est fondu comme un morceau de sucre
dans l'absinthe
[Musique]
nos chansons jours
toutes les armes
- vraiment à chanter
[Musique]
avec toi
on joue des matches
moi vous aurez la ville
cette année
[Musique]
la solitude
d
[Musique]
chantage à traquer la nami chambre de
mon plaisir
jean votre achat
ouais vous sauver la vie
jamais la mi décembre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut-être revenir un jour mais on ne
sait pas quand